la tabla representa el valor anual de
venta de un terreno en una villa remota
a partir del año 1990 qué tipo de
función es la que mejor modela esta
relación este es un ejemplo de los
ejercicios de khan academy y estamos
tratando de elegir entre una función
lineal o una función exponencial que
modele esta relación así que como
siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por ustedes mismos
bueno pensemos en esto juntos tenemos
esta variable de tiempo y vemos que se
incrementa en 2 de 0 a 2 de 2 a 4 de 4 a
6 y así continúa continúa
incrementándose en 2
entonces si esta es una relación lineal
y tenemos que el incremento en el tiempo
es constante nuestro cambio en el costo
debería incrementarse en una cantidad
constante no tiene que ser esta
constante pero tiene que ser una
cantidad constante si se trata de una
relación exponencial
deberíamos multiplicar por la misma
cantidad para un cambio constante en el
tiempo vamos a ver qué está pasando aquí
primero vamos a ver la diferencia entre
estos números para ir de 30 a 36 puntos
9 tenemos que sumar 6.9 y para pasar de
36.9 a 44.1 cuánto tenemos que sumar
tenemos que sumar
7.2 y ahora para pasar de 44.1 a 51.1
tenemos que sumar 7 y para pasar de 51.1
a 57.9 sumamos 6.8 y finalmente para
pasar de 57.9 a 65.1 vamos a ver tenemos
que sumar 7.2 entonces podrías decir oye
no estamos sumando exactamente la misma
cantidad cada vez pero recuerda que se
trata de información que conseguimos en
una situación del mundo real y la
información que conseguimos en
situaciones del mundo real nunca tendrán
exactamente un modelo lineal o
exactamente un modelo exponencial pero
cada vez que sumamos dos años vemos que
estamos muy cerca de sumar siete mil
pesos en el costo 6.9
cerca de 7 este es muy cercano es 7 este
7 este es muy cercano a 7 y este otro es
muy cercano a 7 a mí me parece que es un
modelo lineal podríamos probar si es un
modelo exponencial veamos cuál es el
factor por el cual voy a multiplicar
cada vez bueno no parece que esté
incrementándose exponencialmente no
parece que estemos multiplicando por el
mismo factor cada vez parecería que
estamos multiplicando por un factor
ligeramente menor para obtener el
siguiente costo más alto así que parece
que el modelo lineal es correcto vemos
que cada vez que incrementamos el tiempo
en dos años el costo se incrementa en
6.9 o 7.27 es muy cercano a 7 no es
exactamente el costo pero el modelo
predice muy bien si gráfica moss esto en
un plano ordenado y tratamos de conectar
los puntos se acercaría mucho a una
recta o podríamos dibujar una recta que
estuviera muy cerca de estos puntos